hello everyone that was awesome come get
around applause forestry complete
because I'm gonna forget at the end
thank you to hustle Co and to all of you
guys for being here surround applause
for yourselves it's really important to
tell the stories of women in technology
to help women stay in technology and
also to encourage girls to be in
technology as well and they're just
armed enough stories about women in this
sector or if you see stories about women
in this sector it's mostly about how
they're not there how they're absent so
I admire all of you for coming to this
event and hustle close or putting this
event on I think it's super important so
now I'm going to attempt to share my
story and the hopes that it inspires you
guys in may and may not if you want to
applaud at any moment to give me a
little confidence boost that would be
great I am typically when I'm speaking
publicly it's to a lot of dudes and
hoodies on computers with headphones on
looking at their laptops this is
obviously a different crowd than that
I've heard there are a lot of ladies in
the house right so I'm gonna try and
we'll see how it goes but this is
definitely like a cooler crowd than I'm
used to so I'll share my story with you
guys and as a kid um yeah I'm going all
the way back to childhood this one as a
kid I was one of those kids who tried
everything and quit everything so piano
guitar soccer swimming xylophone which I
hated
selling shoes I sold shoes I was
actually really good at that but I put
that to social media marketing I think
all of us have probably done that at
some point in our careers I tried
everything but nothing really inspired
me and I quit like I was a quitter I was
a super lame person and honestly it took
me twenty six years to discover what my
passion was I know what's shocking
because I look like I'm 19 years old but
I'm not and honestly when I did it kind
of came out of nowhere and was totally
random once she'd done I need a trophy
for everything so yeah so it happened
when I was working as a philanthropy
consultant I was working with high
profile and high net-worth individuals
and nonprofits and foundations doing
glamorous things such as filing IRS
paperwork which were all about to do
that sucks yeah I did that auctioning
off gently used clothes to benefit kids
with disabilities you know all kinds of
really cool stuff like that and I really
loved it I loved working with nonprofits
and getting back and being in the
philanthropy scene but despite the fact
that I was doing that I still you know
just I didn't feel that like I'm like
nothing was pushing me to continue and I
could see it in others around me I was
working with activists and people who
founded nonprofits and founded social
enterprises and done all these campaigns
and and I was inspired by them and I
wanted that like I really wanted that
and I was happy to you know work with
them and kind of you know fold clothes
or do whatever I was doing for them but
you know I didn't feel it and that's
what I wanted so that's what I'm going
to talk to you guys about today is how I
found that thing I know a sort of
reanimate unexpected okay when I had the
opportunity to work on a global campaign
called shine for change which was
founded by Gucci this outfit is not
sponsored by Gucci that's
I actually ran out bought this today
because the girl who runs our PR for a
company said you need to wear long
sleeves and I was like okay I gotta
go buy something with long sleeves
so yeah so trifle change is really
awesome campaign founded by Gucci in the
fashion house focused on empowering
girls and women through education health
and justice and they tasked us with
finding a way to leverage technology to
address tough issues including domestic
violence child marriage universal access
to primary education for girls female
genital mutilation women's health care
and more obviously there's not an app
for that and there never will be but
what we eventually put together was a
hackathon yes we convinced Gucci and
worked with them to put together a
hackathon and that brought together
hundreds of women and men developers
from both sides to build technology
solutions for nonprofits like UN Women
by the voices UNICEF and more I honestly
have no idea how to run a hackathon I
was just like this is gonna be really
cool and we're gonna do it I spent a lot
of time googling what is a hackathon and
I made a bunch of giant complicated
spreadsheets which is you know as women
do
and what resulted honestly blew my mind
it was a room full of people men and
women who were creating really awesome
technology for really hard problems I
mean like you know female genital
mutilation is not not something that's
easy to talk about or even build
technology to solve and they were
building this technology that could have
a real impact in just one weekend and
when I was working in philanthropy I was
working on these projects that would
take months if not years to see any
impact that we're talking millions of
dollars being funneled into things and
not you know kind of hoping it was gonna
work and so to see something built in
one weekend was really inspiring to me
one example was you know a fully working
solution that was a mobile health
services delivery kind of dumb phone
thing for women in rural Africa and lots
of other cool things and I actually
found myself sobbing at the end of the
hackathon which actually is you know if
anyone on my team is here which I think
they are somewhere I can't see you guys
I typically cried every hackathon now
just because I'm so moved by yeah I do I
really do like we actually just did have
gone with Procter and Gamble for Febreze
and I I cried at the end even though
it's just about really awesome smells
because I just but like I really
inspired by the fact that people spend
their time to build something cool that
they're passionate about that could
become you know the next big business or
the next big nonprofit that could have
an impact and you know I'm always moved
by when people have that passion and
that dedication and they want to do more
so yeah so here I am I'm sobbing at the
end of the hackathon and needless to say
I was totally hooked and I just I didn't
you know I knew the hacker was gonna be
cool it was Gucci good she's really
awesome you know it was with Twitter
women who code bunch of cool
organizations but I felt that
immediately even though the hackathon I
was like all right I have to do more to
do more of this I need more of this
giving more of this so fast forward two
years and I basically hunted down a
company
that ran hackathons and that's when I
started working at Angel hack I just
realize I forgot I forgot my names up
there
that's good so I work for a company
called angel hack and my job basically
was my dream job figuring out how to
integrate social impact into every
aspect of Angel hacks work they run
about 100 hackathons a year in 44
countries across the globe so it's like
sweet this is great you know one of the
cool things they did was we created a
global code for impact challenge that
garnered 53 projects in 50 different
cities all over the world and we did pro
bono sponsorships for nonprofits and it
was awesome but same thing at the end of
the charm pack hackathon I was like I
kind of feel like I can do more like I
feel like I can do more what else can I
do and that's you know that's how I knew
I was on to something on to my passion
like that feeling of like as soon as you
accomplish something great you're like
but wait there's probably more probably
more I can do so I started looking at
everything else I was like what more can
I do
you know like so one thing I noticed and
I talked about this a little bit earlier
was the average attendance at hackathon
for women is under 20% so you know I
knew we could improve that I mean for
any of you they do have fun it's
basically a bro fest and the irony is
that angel talks the majority female
owned and operated company so I was like
yeah
um so so yeah so we were like how can we
improve this so we did a bunch of stuff
one of them was you know having gifts in
our newsletters that weren't all white
dudes that was a pretty easy one you
know what other one was partnering
organizations like girls in tech their
CEO is here she's a badass she's gonna
talk shortly after me and we improved
our female tenants by four percent in
just four months something there's a lot
of big tech companies take years to
achieve but for me that's just same
thing you know it's like yeah good job
you got more women it's like not enough
so we decided to design an entire
hackathon series around this called lady
problems yeah yeah so that was super
awesome to try to sell that to sponsors
and big nonprofits and honestly I was
doubting myself I had a lot of people
tell me no I found myself with a on a
phone call with a leading executives and
a fortune 500 company trying to avoid
saying the word period to me but
explaining you couldn't call something
lady problems cuz no one all ten an
event that's around that time of the
month
yeah don't slack and I'm like you knees
periods
after hearing no and that was a bad idea
so many times I was honestly frustrated
and confused and I doubted myself and
that little kid that like kind of quit
everything was like crawling up inside
being like it's time to quit but I was
lucky when my internal voice was muted I
had champions around me pushing me to do
more so our CEO who's female would she
said you know I said hey I think we're
gonna do like three to five events and I
said let's do 15 to 20 and she said
lefty fifteen twenty at least we can do
more I was like okay fine of course my
boss is making me do more than I want to
do our VP of Sales said hey like you
know screw these people who are saying
you can't do it I can sell it and she
went out and sold it we had people like
Procter & Gamble Amazon HPE women who
code a bunch of organizations jumped on
board
I'm the result so I thought this is
gonna be like one or two women in tech
hackathons we did 17 2000 people sign up
for an event some lady problems 60% of
them were female
our goal was 50% so that was pretty cool
we increased by 40% overall in terms of
female attendants in Delhi India where
we typically see just three percent
women code or hackathons that's right
three percent we had 20 percent women
turnout and the team life
and then in Gaza actually is where we
had our highest female turnout of eighty
three percent women and got yeah so I'm
kind of out of time and I have ten more
pages so I'm just kidding
but yeah so you know that's all great
and good and got a lot of women to come
this event but I still think that we can
do more and so we are gonna accelerate
all the wedding teams coming out of
those hackathons from Gaza and Nairobi
London Berlin San Francisco you know
everywhere and because I can't pass up
this opportunity for shameless
self-promotion if you want to support
any of those teams come talk to me
please don't talk to me tomorrow because
I'm going on strike you take away it's
you know you discover your passion when
you're constantly pushing yourself to do
more I know that's a tiger mom thing to
say but as a former quitter
you know you've found it when you think
you can do more so that's it thank you
[Applause]